m
c'est parti pour la quatrième édition du
bonheur des enfants ce mardi 15 décembre
le conseil départemental a inauguré
cette manifestation au jardin de l'état
durant dix jours petits et grands vont
s'immerger dans la magie et la féerie de
noël à vous en vous souhaitant une belle
opération relève enfants venez rené
amener des petits comme des grands
au programme manège patinoire atelier
structures gonflables parade tout cela
au coeur d'un décor enchanteur
de quoi rêver et s'amuser la magie de
noël opère et pas seulement chez les
enfants comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
pour les enfants je trouve que c'est
très intéressant par rapport aux
activités qu'ils proposent surtout
ça leur sort de
de leurs activités de tous les jours il
y avait les poètes les sauts avec les
blues les
e
héroux aussi en plus d'être beaucoup
plus modernes comme la bon vous voyez le
des matelas etc
c'est des choses qu'on fait à la maison
c'est très joli c'est varié c'est varié
puis c'est pour les petits et les grands
je m'amusais tellement c'est bien j'ai
bien doré le spectacle aussi fêté
c'est super j'ai bien aimé on s'amuse
bien et du mal de la suite ou là là on
va commencer à faire la patinoire après
on va faire je trouve que c'est une
bonne soirée surtout avant les vacances
et que voit il ya beaucoup d'activités
que les enfants peuvent en profiter
c'est sur la décoration de votre super
veut et j'ai pris plein de photos et par
ce magnifique surtout le soir après des
relais du rpt et du bien et vient elle
de rien fait pour un sou et je gagne
deux constats j'ai bien aimé la
patinoire le spot 4 de pétards et et la
grande douche ou bien pu sonner là bas
eh bien je suis bien l'onu s'étant
histoire et pour l'occasion le père noël
a quitté son pôle nord pour rencontrer
les petits réunionnais c'est avec
attention qu'il a écoutées chaque veut
que les enfants lui ont soufflé très
bien beaucoup d'enfants plein de chaleur
c'est super de me donner la liste de
cadeaux me demandais planning chose
le petit lutin fonds au travail cette
belle soirée s'est achevée par un
spectacle pyrotechnique où les enfants
ont découvert les quatre saisons
oh
clou du spectacle un feu d'artifice qui
a officiellement lancé le début de noël